ladies and gentlemen good morning
and welcome to Marseille for the 14th
edition of the FTTH conference at the FT
th Council Europe we have a dream a
vision to connect everyone and
everything everywhere every European
citizen should have equal access to
fiber based ultra-high speeds
future-proof broadband each and every
one of us has a role to play in making
this happen together let's build a
brighter future and we count on your
participation during these two days
throughout the ftth conference you will
have plenty of opportunities to get
involved in addition to the things that
you came here for like networking we
have organized several activities for
you if you go to booth g3 in the
exhibition hall you can make a gif of
yourself and on the other side of g3 is
a large white board
in line with the opening clip you are
invited to contribute drawings and text
to create a giant fresco you can also
take your picture in front of it of
course and send it to social media and
we also encourage you of course
to tweet using the hashtag FTTH 2017
these suites will appear on the Twitter
wall which is located in the exhibition
hall last but not least we look forward
to welcoming many of you tonight at our
second annual fibration night party held
at the palais de la booth near the old
port it promises to be great fun with a
live DJ and don't sing so make sure you
pick up your wristbands at the residue
sorry in the registration area before
heading out to the venue tonight
our conference program features
prestigious speakers who came from all
over the globe to share their vision
with us with you